is that me I used to wear blue pants a
city of Grandpa the Citadel of Rick's
all the different Rick's from all the
different realities got together to hide
here from the government
[Applause]
hey youtubers there's a lot of Rick and
Morty theories that have started to gain
more traction after episode 1 of season
3 and one is that Morty is slowly
turning into a Rick metaphorically and
some people believe practically as well
especially starting with the Rick Morty
that we saw during the council scene so
I'm going to play some clips here then
I'll explain context there's currently
more evidence to support it then there
is against it and a lot of it has to do
with the idea of blue pants I used to
wear blue pants is that me I used to
wear blue pants a city of Grandpa the
Citadel of Rick all the different Rick's
from all the different realities got
together so what a coincidence that Rick
used to wear blue pants Rick Morty here
in blue pants looks more like an older
version of Morty than it does like a
younger version of Rick there's a pocket
Morty's example of that too you see a
much older version of Morty it's like
way way older much older than Rick is
but he does start to look a little more
like Rick as he gets older the thing is
is that most Morty's die young you
either die a Morty die young or he lives
long enough to see yourself become the
villain or the antagonist Rick is the
antagonist of the series for Doctor Who
style he stills a hero so like Doctor
Who even though he does good things he
gets crazier and crazier causes bigger
and bigger problems that he then himself
has to fix but the blue pants it's one
of the greatest new conspiracy theory
moments that they have during this
episode I used to wear blue pants then
later in a scene in Jerry's office as
things are going crazy you hear a Morty
voice Justin roiland
doing Morty's voice saying he who
controls the past controls the galaxy
Jimmy your jacket
[Applause]
it's out of context you don't see
whoever it is that's saying it but the
idea that if the Morty voice just throws
flames on that conspiracy theory and
there is this running thing where Morty
slowly gets smarter and smarter as the
series gets on especially when Rick
isn't around when he isn't around he
completely breaks down so you start with
this scene here in the council room he
demonstrates some really complex
reasoning he knows that rick is jumping
bodies coming for the council which the
council itself does not realize and they
themselves are rigs supposedly much
smarter than everyone else in the
universe save for the richest of the
rick c-137 himself what no I don't want
to see your pogs collection I don't run
outs Rick and I never have I was just
trying to protect my sister I wanted you
to have a normal life that's something
you can't have when Rick shows up
everything real turns fake everything
right is wrong all you know is that you
know nothing and he knows everything and
well well he's not a villain summer but
he shouldn't be your hero
he's worked like a demon or the super
[ __ ] up god that's not such the ghost
of his too hard he was a terrorist and
now he's dead yeah if you think my
Rick's dead he's alive and if you think
you're safe he's coming for you breathe
employee of the month ladies and
gentlemen so what are you doing with
Louisville MyAccess anyways destroying
the Galactic government what are you
going to tell all their nukes to target
each other Laurel reprogram their
military portals to disintegrate their
entire space Lee good [ __ ] kids
I'm almost proud but watch closely as
grandpa topples an empire by changing a
one
she was 0 gone wreck 40 I know you're
too stupid to get this but you're really
this up right now I'm not letting you
love my sister die
drop the gun I wasn't gonna let her die
you [ __ ] ha ha point is he thought I
was going to I totally did by the way
you're a [ __ ] Morty Morty you [ __ ]
idiot you're a serious
idiot Morty you basically killed us all
I don't know the back whatever they died
stupid now [ __ ] so you see him be
really smart here then it completely
breaks down at the heat of the moment
here he doesn't kill Rick because he
hates him he kills him because
everybody's yelling at him and he just
can't handle it the rabbit hole goes
even further when you talk about blue
pants there are a lot of things that
Morty is doing that Rick himself has
done in the past somebody fed it to a
Morty these things aren't going to get
through customs unless they're in
someone's rectum Morty no fall right out
of mine I've done this too many times
party now I don't believe that Morty
himself is a rig because that would be
more of a time-travel art in the
creators have said the time travel is
something that they're not going to
touch there is a time travel box in the
background here time travel of stuff but
they said it's more of an easter egg
it's not something that they're playing
with their bread and butter is alternate
realities and I know there are a lot of
you that are still wondering about evil
Morty is c-137 Morty slowly turning in
to evil Morty over the course of the
series he's definitely becoming more
Rick like and it stands to reason that
one of those Morty's the longer he's
traveled with his Rick slowly gets
twisted but I don't think that c-137
himself will turn into the evil Morty of
this series I think they're a little
more positive on it even though they
take it back in moments like this where
do they make you watch him kill Rick but
you see the way he cares for summer it
doesn't seem like evil Morty cares for
other people in that way he uses people
like tools he tortures an army of
himself through the Rick that he's
controlling in his mind human cloaking
devices more you're making a bigger deal
out of this than it is
oh my god Rick look there's a bunch of
people strapped all over that building
not people worry Morty's horrible one
Morty's enough to hide from the
bureaucrats well you get a whole matrix
of Morty's and put him in agonizing pain
that creates a pattern and hide even
from other Rick's mother [ __ ] I fiddled
with concepts like this once on paper
Morty on paper I wouldn't do this it's
barbaric overkill I mean you can
accomplish the same results with like
five Morty's in a jumper cable take his
Morty away come with me yeah gladly
cheese man Rick's huh hey man you seem
to know how this place works is there
any way we could shut down that grid and
rescue all those Morty's outside it
would be pointless Morty's have no
chance of defeating a Rick in here
so it's more plausible that c-137
himself is slowly becoming more of a rig
so let me know in the comments what do
you think Morty's Ark is on Rick and
Morty I love the idea that there is no
complex art for Rick himself I'll find
some more that move on next one teriyaki
dipping sauce Morty that's what this is
all about Morty that's my one arm man
I'm not driven by avenging like that
family Morty that was fake driven by
finding that McNuggets off oh yeah I
want that blue on McNuggets off morning
that's my series are hell if it takes
9th season I want my McNugget yes why
not
Morty that's what's gonna take authority
season nine more seasons morning nine
more seasons until I get that different
sex water ninety seven more years
morning talk about McNuggets [ __ ] it's
all about the Szechuan sauce ninety
seven more years it's going to take nine
more seasons to get that Szechuan sauce
so while the creator's never try to like
throw water on any of the fan theories
Dan Harmon says that he really loves
people making fan theories and he
doesn't want to trample on any of that
that's just their funny way of saying
that most theories won't pan out but
like he's also said traveling with Rick
for prolonged periods of time will
fundamentally change Morty so you go
back and watch those early episodes and
you see the way Morty acts when Rick
tells them about what they're going to
do and then you see a minute later
episodes you see in becoming more
complicit acting more Rick like the
season one Morty would have never tried
to confront the council in the way that
season three Morty is doing right here
so he who controls the pants controls
the galaxy so leave all your requests
for more Rick and Morty videos in the
comments below what's going to happen is
is they still haven't confirmed an exact
premiere date for season three but they
have implies that they're just going to
replay episode one periodically until we
get there now they say summer that could
be late made that could be June I don't
think it's going to be as long as July
but when we get updates I'll post them
but just be sure to leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below the more suggestions you
guys leave the better our discussions
tend to be so what's going to happen
next is is there's a bunch of daredevil
season 3 in Star Wars Celebration is
coming up so there's going to be a whole
bunch of Star Wars stuff posting in the
next week so I'll try to get some of
that out as fast as possible but while
you wait for that to post you can click
here for more new Rick and Morty and you
can click here to rewatch the fake
origin of Rick himself thank you so much
for watching let's high-five I'll see
you guys in the next video
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]